[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au revoir les enfants pauvres
ce soir le long au soudan 11 situé bien
joyeux ce soir nous nous j'espère que
vous avez été sage aujourd'hui et que
vous pourrez danser avec lui sûrement
pas trop vos lions ils sont toujours
sage tous mes petits ou les jeunes au
chalet un grigri ma petite poupée elle
s'appelle tea qui hélas joli collier
aussi m'a fait tout automatique i do
bonsoir les hauts-fonds bourse
ouais petit
bush alors vous êtes prudent sort en
avons pour la danse de giallo et on sait
pas comment ces vacances de 10 alors
c'est très facile
regardez balle au bond avec mais pas
tous des briques sur coup du rythme on
se laisse porter par le rythme doudou et
non je sais mon petit jeu c'est à vous
maintenant fait comme diallo doudou dis
donc c'est plutôt toi qui dansent pas
bien du fil à nicolas aussi grossi pour
ce soir il ne faut pas se laisser
dominer par ce sens primitif
je vois que kiki d'or du vin vous allez
faire comme elle
on y apprenait lamalou jacques était ma
mère on dansera au camp une prochaine
fois
bon d'accord ne mange
[Musique]
ce premier parole debout lourd demain je
vous apporterai une belle surprise à la
ferme et vosges à lisieux jette à 20h02
bonne nuit non non ce bonne nuit nicolas
c'est mon rêve pas preneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous aussi les petits enfants faites
comme nicolas et pimprenelle allez vite
vous coucher à te voilà virtuose du
tam-tam me voir à tron on se plaint de
tuer très doué pour le tam-tam nounours
je sais patron on me l'a déjà dit en
route gros modeste bonne nuit des
enfants faute de boer eu beau